why
so as we pick up with Avengers
disassembled part 2 what we're going to
see with this story is the fallout of
Tony Stark's actions that is to say how
it was that his presumed drunken nature
begins to take its toll on the
relationship that he has with the
Avengers as well as the government and
the world's relationship with the
Avengers but what we're also going to do
is we're going to pick up with the
aftermath of she-hulk and her rampage
during the conflict at Avengers mansion
and we're going to actually see that
things begin to go from bad to worse and
so what we do as we start this story is
we pick up with Tony Stark as he's
speaking with the with the chief of
staff and with the chief of staff tells
Tony Stark is that basically the
president is distancing himself from
Tony Stark that Tony Stark's actions
that his tirade at the United Nations is
going to be broadcast all over the world
and that the best thing Tony Stark can
really do right now is tender his
resignation is to walk away from the
position of Secretary of Defense now the
chief of staff doesn't necessarily say
this directly in terms of Tony Stark
being fired but this is pretty much what
he alludes to he asked Tony Stark if he
really has to ask for his resignation
and what this basically means with the
chief of staff speaking on behalf of the
president is that if tony stark doesn't
tender his resignation then Tony Stark
is going to be fired and so what happens
here is we see that his Tony Stark is
speaking with the chief of staff that he
says that he has to leave because
there's an event an emergency at
Avengers mansion that requires his
attention and so he dons his Iron Man
armor and he immediately takes off from
here we pick up with Shi hook and again
we're continuing with Shi hoax rampage
at Avengers mansion where she's going
against Captain America as well as other
Avengers and what takes place here is
basically Captain America doing what he
can using a shield to keep his physical
body protected because again at this
point she hoped possesses a vast amount
of strength in a fully enraged state
more so than most any of the Avengers
would be able to go against we of course
see that Kelsey lay that Lionheart or I
guess the previous iteration of a new
version of Captain
Rico is doing we're I'm sorry of Captain
Britain is doing what she can to try to
stop she-hulk but with the sort of mind
she's really still not able to do much
against she hopes onslaught and so as
things continue with she-hulk going on
her rampage we eventually see that while
characters like Clint Barton are trying
to talk her down while other Avengers
are trying to get her to calm down that
ultimately it's Iron Man who arrives on
the scene and is able to resume ibly
knock her unconscious and so what I earn
man does alongside Hawkeye is they take
their attention away from she-hulk and
they are focusing on Captain America and
what Hawkeye asks the Iron Man is
whether or not he can lift this giant
vehicle off of Captain America to see
what's going on with Captain America
underneath and what a Iron Man says
it'll take a couple seconds for his
armor to magnetize and once it's
magnetized he'll actually be able to
pick up the vehicle and move it away or
at the very least push it over and make
sure that Captain America is safe
underneath and this is what they find
they find that basically Captain America
isn't he's not dead he's not even
unconscious that his shield of course
was able to keep him protected but at
this point we don't know what sort of
physical injuries his body has sustained
but what we also do is we see that Sam
Wilson has arrived but he's holding
Janet Van Dyne in her wasp form in her
very very small form and he says that I
have the only thing he could really
think to do was to pick her up even
though he knew he shouldn't have but
that he's going to try to get her to the
hospital to get her some kind of a some
kind of medical treatment but once we
realize that a giant man that Hank Pym
is on the scene Hank Pym looks and sees
that Janet Van Dyne is completely
unconscious that she is still stuck in
her aunt form and this is very
disconcerting to him and so what he does
is he picks up Sam Wilson who is
currently holding Janet Van Dyne and
takes her to the hospital now from here
we switched to the Beth Israel Hospital
where Sam Wilson and Captain America are
currently getting medical treatment and
of course Captain America is having his
shoulder popped into place which is
truly the only I guess the only real
damage he sustained at the hands of she
hooks onslaught but what we also do as
we see both Sam Wilson and Falcon I'm
sorry a Sam Wilson in Captain America
talking about everything that's going on
so far talking about everything that's
taking place trying to figure out what
they're going to do try to figure out
what else happened
but then we see Captain America asking
the doctor how everybody else is doing
and so what we do is we get this brief
explanation of some of the other
characters we of course see that Kelsey
ley again Lionheart is unconscious she's
in critical condition and this is
actually how her character will remain
for the remainder of this of this
Avengers disassembled event it won't be
until after the event comes to an end as
she travels back to London to re-enter
take the role of Captain Britain and to
keep protecting the the city once more
but we also see that Jennifer Walters is
now in some sort of a stasis pod and
she's basically being kept unconscious
by shield under the control of Nick Fury
we learn of course that Scott Lang is
completely dead that his body is
presumably was completely incinerated or
at the very least it's in a condition
where he simply just kept in a kept in
the morgue and we of course see the
visions body has been ripped in part
ripped in half at the hands of few Hulk
and his body appears to be kept in some
kind of a warehouse now from here we
switch to Hank Pym and a Janet Van Dyne
and this is a very important moment with
Hank Pym and the reason why is because
Hank Pym is not only telling us that
because of Janet Van Dyne small form the
doctors can't operate on her and that
he's basically been sending the doctors
all the schematics and all the
blueprints and all the information that
he has involving her physical structure
as well as all the information that he
has about her but he begins to talk to
her begins to basically speak with her
about his life and his perception of her
with regards to them being divorced and
what he tells us here is that in his
life he's made a lot of mistakes he's
done a lot of different things that he's
been yellowjacket he's been giant man
he's been ant-man but the one thing that
he laments the most is that of all of
his actions the one thing he'll be
remembered for is that he created Ultron
now this I would say I would go as far
as to say is a little callous on behalf
of Hank Pym then the reason why is
because as we know Hank Pym had hit his
wife he had hit Jan Van Dyne and the
fact that he never addresses this the
fact that he says that he's never
actually sorry about this tells us that
either he doesn't think that it's a
major issue or that he simply just
doesn't remember it happening but we
know that he remembers that happening
because it's brought up to him all the
time and so it seems as though this
isn't really a
CERN for him but again he's kind of
going through this grieving process he's
going through this state where he's
trying to come to terms with the fact
that Janet Van Dyne may very well die
here at this point we transition back to
Captain America to Sam Wilson to iron
man and a Hawkeye and they're basically
talking about the events as they
unfolded they're talking about
everything that's taking place here of
course they all unanimously agree that
they're under attack but the question is
who are they under attack by but we also
see iron man saying is that this is an
incredibly bad day but Hawkeye it
capitalizes on this and saying that it's
not a bad day that is an extraordinarily
bad day and the reason why is because
they are extraordinary people whether
it's because they have superpowers or
whether it's because they simply have
enhanced skills as compared to any other
human being the fact remains that
because they are extraordinary people
they have either extraordinarily good
days or they have extraordinarily bad
days but what Hawkeye also says is they
had basically had this kind of a day
coming that it was only a matter of time
before something like this happened then
again the reason is because they
basically go against a conflict they
focus on what's in front of them and
then as soon as the conflict is over
they move on to the next thing and never
really focus on the aftermath and he
uses Jack of Hearts as a perfect example
here that when Jack of Hearts had taken
off into space presumably having having
blown up they assumed that was just the
case they assumed that he had just blown
up and that was it and they had never
done any investigation other than that
but come to find out Jack of Hearts was
apparently maybe survived as his
explosion or at the very least his body
was not physically destroyed and so he
simply just showed up at Avengers
mansion and blew up the way that he
always feared now this is a very
important thing that Hawkeye is saying
when he says that it was the biggest
fear that that Jack of Hearts had that
he was going to explode and the reason
why is because as we progress further
into this story and we learned why the
Scarlet Witch had gone crazy we'll pick
up on things about how she's basically
manipulating the fears of people Tony
Stark being drunk at the United Nations
was a fear that he had and we saw that
fear coming to fruition but from here we
also see again that they start talking
about the idea of Ultron they start
talking about the attack that it come
from Ultron when vision started spitting
out all these different versions of
Ultron and what Sam will
son does here is he says that maybe this
was a maybe some kind of contingency
plan that Ultron had installed in the
vision that whenever the Avengers had
sent out a code white which was their
basic basically their code for
desperation when they were at their
worst moment that the vision would
automatically I guess initiate this
protocol that had previously been
programmed and in by Ultron and starts
spitting up these Ultron robots which
would allow for the almost immediate
destruction of the Avengers and the
other Avengers seem to agree on this
Hawkeye and and Captain America and Iron
Man seem to seem to agree that this may
very well be a reasonable argument to
make but what Hawkeye also says is that
they don't really know how to kill
Ultron and this is one of the reasons
why this may be a true statement that
whole Tron
Ultron's artificial intelligence they
don't really know how it is that he
sustained his life he says that it may
be that Ultron keeps himself alive and
Tony Stark's armor there's really no way
for them to know this and so again he
says that when when you look at the
Avengers team they have Bruce Banner on
the Avengers they had she-hulk on the
Avengers they had these giant characters
who were absolutely massive and their
physical strength but are mentally
unstable and then suddenly the Avengers
are surprised when everything backs
fought backfires
this is basically Hawkeye making the
argument that again something like this
was bound to happen it was simply just a
matter of time but what we do is we see
that as Tony Stark begins to tell the
Avengers about his about what had gone
on at the United Nations that Hank Pym
shows up and Hank Pym is absolutely
livid he immediately tells Tony Stark to
tell everybody what had happened before
Tony Stark is able to actually explain
Hank Pym tells the rest of the Avengers
that Tony Stark was drunk but he got up
in front of the United Nations
threatened to kill the latverian
ambassador and started on lamb bassing
other ministers and again
Hawkeye says I'm sorry I'm ant-man says
this was a total disaster this was an
absolute fiasco and that Tony Stark had
basically set in to set into motion a
series of events that will lead to the I
guess disavow Minh of the Avengers
overall but what Tony Stark says here is
that he wasn't drunk that he hadn't had
any alcohol that he had the feeling of
being drunk that he wasn't in control
but that he had not had any
alcohol so the question that has to be
asked here its what's happened and what
he says here is he think that everything
is connected he thinks that the events
add up with regards to Jack of Jack of
Hearts blowing up the Avengers mansion
he thinks Ultron attacking the Avengers
mansion he thinks that she hoped
flipping out and going to an enraged
state that all of these things are
connected with Tony Stark going or I
guess presumably being drunk and
freaking out at the United Nations but
nobody seems to believe him it seems as
though no one really thinks that he's
telling the truth
and to a degree the Avengers have a
basis for this and the fact that of
course with stories like demon in a
bottle and with Iron Man's past he has
consistently been a person that has
turned to alcohol
whenever things got too stressful now
Captain America steps up and says that
he believes him and while Sam Wilson
says that he he follows Captain America
here
Sam Wilson doesn't really say that he
believes Iron Man he doesn't really say
that he thinks Iron Man is telling the
truth and of course Hawkeye is is quite
adamant in his stance that he thinks
that that Iron Man was drunk he talks
about how Iron Man's or that Hawkeye his
dad was an alcoholic and then again one
of the things that alcoholics constantly
say is that they're not drunk that they
can stop drinking at any time and so
again we basically see that as Ironman
is arguing with the Avengers and the
Avengers seem as though they don't
believe what it is at Ironman is saying
that Ironman simply just leaves what we
also do is we pick back up with the
Avengers Quinn jet I guess the other
Avengers as they're landing in in
Central Park as they're meeting with
people trying to figure out what's going
on and when they actually arrive back at
the Avengers mansion what they see is
that all of the reserve Avengers all
everybody who was previously Avenger or
is an Avenger and wasn't there is now
here and they're trying to again figure
out what all is going on
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace